last week i made a video on seven books
that completely changed my life
and then i realized that not many people
like to read so that is why i'm here to
share with you
seven tips to help you start a reading
habit even if you hate to read
these tips are inspired by the book
atomic habits by james clear
which is actually what helped me pick up
reading and
change several other habits in my life
number one
remove barriers or excuses that you
might use
for example if you fall asleep while
reading books then don't read on a bed
if you're tempted to check your cell
phone then put it away or turn it off
if your family is always watching tv
then don't read in the same room that
they're in
chances are your attention might stray
the main thing here is to think of
excuses and barriers that you might
normally use
and find a way to remove those number
two set
cues to remind you to read have you ever
tried to start a habit
and you ended up quitting on it only
because you kept forgetting to do it
for this set cues place the book where
you can't miss it
for example i had gotten out of habit of
reading my bible every night for me
that's important so what i ended up
doing was placing my bible
directly on the bed so that that way
every time
i had to undo the bed to get in i had to
physically hold the book in my hand
which was a cue to me to read it if you
plan to read on your favorite chair for
example then place it directly
on your chair or place it somewhere
nearby or if you plan to read at a
specific time
then set an alarm your cue can actually
be a habit that you already have which
is even more powerful
for example if you normally like to
drink your a cup of coffee every morning
then place your book beside your coffee
machine and
you can read while you drink your
favorite cup of coffee
number three make it pleasurable our
brains naturally want to do things that
bring us pleasure
because it brings that dopamine spike
that tells us it's rewarding
but if you hate reading you can actually
use this as leverage by using
things that you already enjoy and find
pleasurable to associate with reading
for example use your favorite comfy
chair that you like
or pour yourself a cup of coffee or tea
if that's something that you enjoy
or use warm lighting for me i love fuzzy
blankets i have one in like every room
and it helps me just kind of set the
vibe so to say and try to have a
designated place where you can read and
focus
you know maybe not right next to the
refrigerator number four
take it slow don't start off with huge
goals like reading one book per week
because it's only going to weigh you
down
the key here is to make small easy to
achieve goals that
you will repeat every day repetition is
what makes a habit
not the amount of time that you do it
for so maybe it's only reading a chapter
per day or reading 15 minutes per day
the key here is to make the goal small
so that's much more likely that this
repeated action
will become a habit number five
eliminate
idle time this is that time that you're
not really doing anything too productive
like when you're waiting for an oil
change
or during a commute if you're like me
and you drive a lot
try listening to audiobooks during your
commute okay sure you don't exactly flip
pages but you still absorb the
information
or if you're going to wait for an oil
change or wait at the doctor's office
then
just take the book with you number six
is accountability you can do this by
yourself or with other people
but the key is to make specific goals
set a specific time and location and
follow through
actually schedule it in your calendar
when you schedule something like you do
an appointment it's much more likely
that you're actually going to do it
you can also try tracking your progress
through habit tracking apps or by
journaling about what you've read
if you prefer a team approach then join
a book club
or start reading with someone that will
keep you accountable and actually
motivate you to keep going as well
and number seven choose wisely choose a
book that you will
actually enjoy i am a total science nerd
i could actually read this bad boy for
fun
but if reading about enzymes and
photosynthesis is something that would
put you to sleep
then find a book that you find
interesting through an activity or a
topic that you actually enjoy
maybe read a smaller book if pictures is
your thing find a book with pictures
you can also ask friends for
recommendations or even just read
reviews
and if you're getting bored by a book
then switch it out and start a new one
in this case you don't have to finish
what you started because the key is
to keep the habit instead of stopping
all together because this one book
is torture and if you're trying to pick
up healthy habits or cut out unhealthy
habits from your life
i highly recommend the book atomic
habits by james clear
it gives you a systematic approach to
analyzing your habits to see where you
can make small changes
to get amazing results i will leave the
link in the description
that is it for today guys if you found
any of these tips helpful please give it
a thumbs up
and subscribe so that you won't miss out
on my weekly videos i thank you so much
for watching and i can't wait to see you
in the next one